you
worked with no limit sports yes master p
at the time was the hottest [ __ ] moving
yes i had a little fake no limit chain
when i was 12 like
man no limit was insane for you know for
their run
and master p starting a sports agency
was kind of like you know i don't think
i think the only other person who was
doing something similar that was jay
prince when he was doing boxing and
managing floyd mayweather right
because this was before there was rock
nation sports all that how did you link
with master p
outside of being in the same city you
know you're in new orleans we ended up i
mean
i linked up with them when i was in
school in austin still
and and you know what typically what
happens is agents have runners
you know agents usually don't go after
the players they hire someone younger
that can relate to the players and they
create the relationships and then they
introduce you to the agent
and so terry he's doing an interrogator
that was his runner yeah i was his
runner
and me and terry were just cool you know
we were just cool
and and you know i just knew he was
connected to no limit sports and like
you said p was like
was was everything everything everything
you know especially me coming from
southern california
going to school in texas and being just
being introduced to that that all that
whole other one oh that okay it was
it was real you know uh fat pad mjg
yeah it was yeah it was so it was like
you know
mind expanding for me and you know no
limit was was it was a big part of that
and so
i had an agent because i was a baseball
player so i had an agent and i just
thought i would keep that agent into
football
but that relationship fell apart and so
i didn't have an agent and then so all
the like the normal dudes started coming
at me
they just felt like grimy and so i
thought about and i said
you know i'm at the top right now p is
at the top like this could be an amazing
like partnership that really opens up
people's minds to
doing things differently right you don't
always have to go to that to that same
guy that you know
right we can overlap the world and so i
i you know i said let's let's do this
and the contract that you that they
negotiated for you
was a was was did it end up like
did you ever regret making that decision
of course of course
of course of course but you know it's
it's not a negative regret it's
that regret like i was young and naive
and i had like these idealistic ideas
about what i wanted to do with my nfl
career
and i don't regret that you know my i
just remember growing up and hearing
people complain about overpaid athletes
and i just didn't i wanted to be
different and so
what i told pea in in in leland my agent
is i said here's what i want you know
because i knew
you know there's a there's a uh every
team has a certain amount of money that
they get in order to sign up
it's a rookie salary yeah and so um and
so i knew i was the only
i was the only draft pick that year and
so i said just give me the max
of whatever that rookie salary cap
number is
and then i'll make the minimum and make
everything else be based off incentives
so it was your idea to have everything
incentive it was it was me and then
and they tried to talk me out of it they
said listen you have all this leverage
and you have an opportunity you know to
be the highest paid rookie ever in the
history of the nfl
and you were like nah and i said it
didn't feel right i mean
it didn't feel right yeah i was young i
mean looking back i'm like
what the hell you know but but it just
didn't feel right to me at the time
you know i didn't i didn't want to it
didn't feel right i wanted to earn it
but and the one so what i regret is i
didn't consider
what if i get hurt and i can't play and
then my first preseason game i get a bad
ankle spray and i end up missing
10 games my first two seasons and so
um that it backfired but you know once i
got healthy
you know i put up numbers where i you
know i hit those incidents